bonsoir édition spéciale du 78 politique
consacré en ce 23 mars au premier tour
du scrutin des départementales nous
allons faire un point complet sur les
différents résultats les différents
chiffres dans le département et
justement vous allez voir s'afficher le
nouveau rapport de force dans les zblin
l'Union de la Droite du centre et qui
est en tête avec 21,17 % des suffrages
et il faudrait y ajouter également le
score des binômes uniquement porté par
l'UMP dans le détail cela se traduit
donc par 21 premières places dans 21
cantons des Yvelines pour la droite le
Front national arrive second dans le
département le parti de Marine Le Pen
qui arrive à qualifier pour le second
tour h binômes dans les yelin le PS est
donc 3e un autre chiffre à vous donner
c'est celui de la participation dans les
evelines pour ce premier tour car 45,34
% des électeurs se sont déplacés aux
urnes c'est 5 points de moins qu'au
niveau national dimanche soir sur TVfil
hier donc vous avez pu suivre la
première soirée électorale bien sûr je
donne d'ors et déjà rendez-vous dimanche
prochain pour avoir les résultats
complet à partir de 19h45 mais pour
l'instant écoutons les réactions des
alliés de la droite et du centre ils
étaient en plateau et ils se sont
félicités de leur rapprochement qui
s'est avéré payant l'UMP et l'UDI
arrivent nettement en tête de cette
élection personne ne le nit euh et donc
c'est une c'est la révélation de ces
élections car la révélation de ces
élections c'est qu'on disait le Front
national va être le premier parti de
France et bah écoutez il paraît que au
QG je sais pas moi j'ai écouté la radio
hetenant ils ont supprimé les affiches
qui disaient Front national premier
parti de France l'Union c'est toujours
un exercice difficile nous avions
beaucoup de sortants l'UMP en avait
beaucoup également ça ça a marché
effectivement les électeurs il ont été
très sensibles les électeurs ont été
sensibles à cette alliance est-ce que
c'est une alliance durable solide qui
préfigure la fut vous inviter précédent
que chaque élection a sa propre économie
donc il faut pas regarder les cantonales
ou les départementales par rapport aux
européennes ou par rapport aux
régionales à venir voilà la situation le
mode de scrutin tout à fait particulier
ce système avec les binômes un peu
spécifiques et nouveau nécessitaé à mon
avis pour que nous nous déchirions pas
au quatre coins des des Yvelines une
stratégie du Dion voilà elle a réussi le
prochain scrutin à un mode de scrutin
complètement différent il faut et là la
stratégie c'était quoi juste juste on va
dire juguler le front nationalir le
fronttion c'est pas le sujet c'est pas
le sujet c'était de présenter les
meilleurs candidats aux électeurs
ivelinois je seraai peut-être un petit
peu plus nuancé Carn Richard il y a y a
il y a un constat quand même qui est
clair c'est que ce que fait le
gouvernement socialiste en ce moment est
assez catastrophique pour le pays donc
en ce compte là vous avez bien vu qu'au
niveau national on est quand même plutôt
dans l'opposition pas surtout c'est vrai
par exemple je pense que si on avait eu
des déput député à l'Assemblée on aurait
voté la loi Macron même si c'est pas la
loi du siècle hein soyons clair mais ça
faisait sauter quelques petits bouchons
voilà donc après sur le département
écoutez sur le département c'était
presque implacable comme logique puisque
je vous l' ai dit les résultats étaient
plutôt bons en terme de gestion c'est le
premier département d'Île-de-France
c'est le 10e de France d'après nos vos
confrères de BFM Business alors après on
me ressortira des chiffres le constat
est là bien évidemment donc pour nous la
base étant solide et sachant qu'on
allait pouvoir travailler concrètement
derrière sur une dynamique qui existe
pas seulement depuis pierre béer ni
Alain Schmitz mais qui existe depuis
Franck Borotra il y avait pas
d'incohérence puisque sur le projet on
était d'accord le Front national sera
bien présent au second tour des
départementales dans les Yvelines dans
huit cantons plus précisément notamment
à montelajolie ou encore à Rambouillet
sur ce second canton le binôme porté par
Christine Boutin et George bénise
soutenu par l'Union de la Droite devance
d'à peine 1000 voix le Front national
quant au président sortant du conseil
départemental Pierre Bédier il se
retrouve face face au maire de
mantelaville le Front national Cyril not
c'est un large motif de satisfaction
pour Philippe Chevrier le responsable
départemental de la formation de Marine
Le Pen écouteter sa réaction toujours
hier sur ce plateau l'UMP toute seule je
crois pas que ça fasse 26 % hein le
Parti socialiste tout seul je crois pas
que ça fasse 26 % donc si on veut bien
être sérieux et si on veut comparer des
choses comparables c'est-à-dire des
partis avec des partis le Fond national
reste je suis j'enis je suis désolé
hein je suis désolé pour vous le premier
parti de
France é donc forte hier entre l'UMP le
FN retour sur un échange entre Philippe
Chevrier donc et et Pierre lequillet
député UMP des ivelines ils échangeaient
sur cette antenne sur les résultats de
leur formation mais également sur la
situation de Pierre Bédier j'ai lu un
tract ce matin du Front national pu oui
puisque je je votais donc j'ai lu quand
même et je me suis aperçu que vous ne
proposiez rien
que vous dénonciez des choses mais que
vous ne proposiez rien bon ben c'est pas
comme ça que il va falloir que j'invite
les gens aller voir le site du Front
national pour voir ce qu'on propose
véritblement connaissez pas les
compétences alors il faut savoir où on
les connait les compétences on les
connait pas voilà bon alors ça suffit
quoi
séux allezy Chac vot
tour
sur les compétences n'était pas
terminées mais on s'oriente si j'ai bien
compris vers un maintien en fait des
compétences du département c'est-à-dire
alors nous on a vu ce que c'est la
gestion UMP on l'a vu dans les communes
on sait comment ça se passe la hausse de
de de la masse salariale en permanence
euh le transfert de c'est c'est c'est
tout à fait vrai c'est tout à fait vrai
sur regarder le budget du Conseil
Général des zvine au contraire nous
avons nous avons mené une poque80
personnes 480 personnes ben vous savez
on est on est chargé de l'aide sociale
dans dans auprès des des personnes âgées
et des enfants et ben j'invite toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont voulu
manifester leur colère leur
désapprobation et cetera en votant Front
national à apportter leur soutien un
autre candidat qui je l'espère va être
conseiller général dimanche prochain les
socialistes pourraient donc être les
grands perdants de l'élection dimanche
prochain la droite et le centre en passe
de réaliser un grand schlem reste donc à
mobiliser au plus vite ceux qui ne sont
pas venus aux urnes c'est le message de
la responsable du parti socialiste dans
le département mobilisation mobilisation
jusqu'au bout on sait qu'il faut aller
chercher pour la gauche les voix une par
une que rien n'est acquis rien n'est
perdu non plus donc euh on va faire ce
travail- làà pendant une semaine de de
terrain comme on sait le faire pour
expliquer aux gens les enjeux parce que
moi je voudrais pas que demain dans ce
département dans lequel on vit tous le
l'opposition à Pierre Bédier ça soit
Christine Boutin et le FN je trouve ça
très malsin je pense que puisque c'est
pas des scrutins de liste il y a pas de
représentation de fait que fassiez 20 %
25 % comme force politique vous n'êtes
pas représenté si vous êtes pas donc sur
un un canton où vous avez réussi à
passer les 50 donc il faut que nos
concitoyens ai conscience de ces
enjeux-là que là on est en capacité de
gagner il y a ce réflexe de se dire ben
voilà c'est peut-être que sur d'autres
sujets je suis pas d'accord parce que je
suis vert plutôt électeur vert et puis
là c'est des candidat PS peut-être que
certains se disent bah moi la politique
du gouvernement c'est pas c'est pas trop
mon truc ou j'ai besoin d'explication
mais là l'enjeu c'est pas ça l'enjeu
c'est est-ce que on laisse Pierre Bédier
face- à faceace avec Boutin madame
Boutin pardon madame pécrè parce que je
trouve ça démocratiquement très malsin
et puis c'est pas c'est pas bon pour la
suite non plus la gauche très divisée
donc vécu une soirée difficile pour ses
anciens alliés aucun regret l'un des
responsables locaux d'Europe Écologie
Les vert nous explique l'incompatibilité
de leurs aspirations avec la politique
actuelle pour un éventuel rapprochement
pendant l'entre de tour cela se règlera
au cas par cas mon analyse de la
situation c'est que le Parti socialiste
enfin le gouvernement mène une une une
politique une idéologie libérale
libérale mais
férroce c'est une idéologie libérale qui
s'appuie sur une méthode qui est la
libre concurrence et donc comment ça on
a du mal à imaginer qu'il puiss avoir un
appel à voter pour le parti socialiste
au second tour oui mais non parce que
après on verra mais en tout cas je tiens
quand même à expliquer pourquoi av par
nousons pu dès le départ effectivement
essayer de nous associer le Parti
socialiste mais nous avons voulu lancer
un
message en faisant cette cette alliance
avec d'autres forces de gauche qui ell
étai proche de de ce que je suis en
train de dire et je pense moi que cette
politique libérale elle est incompatible
avec nos valeurs de de de de démocratie
de de de solidarité et surtout
écologique le 78 politique qui se
poursuit avec quelques réactions des
figures du département à présent beno
Amon député PS élu à trp au conseil
municipal souhaite au plus vite le
rassemblement de l'ensemble des forces
de gauche Valérie pcres député
responsable UMP dans les zblin appelle à
une mobilisation générale pour amplifier
la dynamique quant à David Douillet
député UMP également il revient sur
l'alliance de la droite et du centre au
micro de Mathilde capberne les électeurs
sont assez lucides en réalité ils ont su
discerner que l'union de du centre de la
droite euh
est une union qui va vers l'intérêt
général alors que la désunion de la
gauche d à ce qui s'est passé notamment
à l'Assemblée au Sénat sur différentes
lois et notamment la laro l'explosion de
la gauche montre que la politique
politicienne a atteint ses limites et
les gens le perçoivent ça nous allons à
présent revenir sur les résultats par
canton sur notre secteur des ivelines
tout d'abord le canton de Montini le
Bretonneux un duel indécis entre le
sortant le soci socialiste François de
Ligier avec son binôme et le président
de la casquille le divers droite Michel
logier le maire de Guill en cours face
au maire de Montini Mélanie
poquet le duel aura finalement bien lieu
le binô union de la droite composé de
Michel logier et Laurence Trochu
arrivent en tête au premier tour avec
40,65 % des voix les socialistes
François de Lig et Sandrine grandangambe
obtiennent 35,93 % des suffrages le
Front national lui obtient 14,30 % et le
binôme divivers gauche 9,13 % des voix
un résultat qui satisfait le maire de
Montini Michel logier ce résultat vous
l'attendiez ce résultat je l'attendais
je l'espérais et pour moi c'est une
belle belle réussite après une bonne
campagne donc ça veut dire que les
habitants de Montin sont fidèles à leur
mère et souhaitent qu'il les
accompagneent encore plus loin et les
habitants de guilloncour aussi souhaite
que je les représente au sein de
l'assemblée départementale du côté des
socialistes on préfère saluer la
mobilisation des électeurs et se
projeter directement vers le deuxème
tour de scrutin moi je je suis satisfait
de ce premier tour je suis satisfait
parce qu'on voit que les habitants de
Montini et de guillancour ont compris
qu'il fallait se mobiliser alors
évidemment on souhaiterait tous qui est
plus de participation je pense que pour
le deuxème tour il va falloir à un
moment donné avoir une mobilisation
supplémentaire c'est certains mais qu'on
peut très bien contrairement à ce qui
éta annoncé encore une fois faire la
différence 194 voix seulement sépare les
deux binômes présents au second tour
cela devrait donc se jouer avec le
report de voix en ce qui n concerne les
conses de vote ont toujours été très
clair là-dessus on ne se désiste
absolument pas en faveur d'un autre
parti pour les consignes de vote on va
pas décider ça nous tout seul donc on va
se réunir avec les sympathisants avec
les militants et demain on pourra
prendre une décision la décision du binô
Front de Gauche Europe Écologie Les
Verts devrait être connu
mardi nous partons pour pour trappe à
présent le canton de trappe où les
socialistes sortant sont là aussi
dominés par la liste de
l'UMP plus de 38 % des suffrages
exprimés pour le duo a en courtois
Jean-Michel Fourgous Anne capio la liste
de l'Union de la Droite réalise un bon
premier tour sur le canton de trappe
même si l'abstention est à prendre en
compte 63 % sur l'ensemble du secteur et
jusqu'à 70 % sur la ville de trappe quel
est votre sentiment mais écoutez d'abord
bien sûr la prudence parce
que il faut pas CR victoire voilà et et
et puis surtout non moi moi je dirais la
bonne nouvelle de cela on sent bien
entendu qu'il y a une vague bleue dans
ma ville je le sens bien très fortement
bon et et puis globalement même sur le
canton on sent bien une différence voilà
qui est claire le maire d'élancour et
son adjointte porté par leur ville ou un
électeur sur deux leur font confiance la
gauche était divisée dans ce scrutin
fond de gauche et Europe Écologie les
vers préférant s'allier laissant seul le
Parti socialiste
les socialiste pourtant sortant sur ce
canton et qui arrive second avec 29,88
%. maintenant il y a une semaine pour
mobiliser les abscentionnistes et
s'assurer que l'éroport de gauche
fonctionne bien puisqu'il y a
effectivement des réserves de voie à
gauche importantes donc on on va aller
les chercher à la fois sur la deuxè
liste et puis à la fois sur les
absentionnistes la liste Front de Gauche
Europe Écologie Les ver qui totalise
11,07 % et qui appelle aujourd'hui à
battre la droite dans un communiqué
diffusé par son candidat Luc misery
quant au Front national porté par le
binôme Maribo Nicolas Boer il arrive 2
sur la ville même de trappe avec 797
voix mais seulement 3e dans le canton
avec 16,21 %. je voudrais quand même
dire un mot sur sur la commune d'
lancour on a quand même
doublé notre score par rapport aux
élections municipales pour laquelle
j'avais été candidat et élu he au
conseiller municipal donc je pense que
que cet ancrage se fait de manière enfin
s'impose même comme comme a dit tout à
l'heure votre confrère par un lapsus
plutôt rigolo on dire le Front national
s'impose dans le canton euh je je crois
que tout ce travail que j'ai mené depuis
un an au conseil municipal à porter ses
fruits bien évidemment je continuerai ce
travail de de de terrain aucune consigne
de vote pour le Front national le canton
de trappe a été remagé depuis le dernier
scrutin puisque dorén avant et l'encours
et la verrière y sont
rattachés mort pas maintenant dans les
résultats les cantons sur lesquels nous
regardons les résultats c'est un canton
particulier celui-ci suite au
redécoupage de conseillers
départementaux s'affronte Yve vanval
pour l'UMP Ismaïl avan pour les
socialistes avec bien sûr leur binôes
respectifs Floran
parfet deux conseillers généraux sortant
en duel c'est le résultat du premier
tour des élections départementales 2015
pour le canton de morpa avec 41,12 % le
duo Rosetti vanval une union UMP udi
récolte le plus de voix largement tête
devant le binôme pS je pense que c'était
une stratégie nécessaire les gens ne
comprennent pas les divisions de la
droite surtout à l'échelon local où rien
ne les justifie et par conséquent
effectivement je crois que ça a été une
stratégie intelligente rationnelle pour
gérer au mieux et continuer de bien
gérer le département des Yvelines le
Parti socialiste lui n'a pas fait
d'alliance pour ses élections avec un
score de 22,27 % sur les 16 communes du
canton Ismaël avan conseiller général
sortant élu à morpa en 2008 garde espoir
pour le second tour ma candidature en
tant que conseiller général sortant à
vocation de
rassembler toutes les forces qui ont
vocation à adhérer à notre à notre
projet mais au-delà de ça nous on a axé
notre campagne sur le local sur le bilan
qu'on a qu'on a produit qui est qui est
un bon bilan donc on invite tous les
morpasiennes tous les morpasiens tous
les habitants de ce du canton de morpas
à se rejoindre pour créer une dynamique
pour le second tour du côté de l'umpudi
on appelle également à la mobilisation
des électeurs le binôme union de la
droite affirme que rien n'est gagné pour
le second tour malgré des résultats
conséquents comme sur la commune de
voisin le Bretonneux où le duo a
remporté 52,17 % des suffrages exprimés
les candidats s'inquiètent des résultats
du binôme du Front national le FN
talonne le binô PS et remporte 17,39 %
des suffrages sur le canton quand on
voit les candidats qui ont été présentés
dont on ne sait absolument rien dont on
avait même pas la photo des suppléants
on sait pas où ils habitent on sait je
suis un peu inqui
de me dire qu'on puisse voter pour pour
des inconnus et en même temps ça veut
bien dire que il y a un message qui est
passé au politiques aujourd'hui donc sur
la commune de touss leenble le binôme
Front national arrive second avec 23,22
% des suffrages exprimés derrière
l'Union de la Droite dans le conton de
morpa socialiste avant son redécoupage
l'année dernière le Front national ne
compte que 44 voix de moins que le
binôme va Mercier moi je suis
relativement satisfait vraiment
satisfait parce que le but c'est
vraiment de se rapprocher le plus
possible du PS on savait que c'était
suivant le découpage un quanton assez
difficile pour frond national
l'argumentaire de marine et et sa
pédagogie sa manière d'expliquer les
choses sont vraiment très importantes et
nous ideent forcément ici aussi à morpa
le tandem divers droite sans étiquette
politique se classe lui en 4e position
il récolte 10,59 % des voix et dresse
une analyse en demi-teinte de ce premier
tour nous avions adopté une démarche
assez originale hein puisque on était
chapaoté par aucune étiquette politique
donc c'est quand même c'est quand même
c'est quand même ambitieux comme on dit
c'était aussi extrêmement risqué Mor pas
55 % d'abstention c'est énorme c'est
décevant deuxièmement il y a une forte
poussée de l'extrême droite du Front
national c'est énorme c'est décevant pas
de consigne de vote au second tour pour
le binôme divivers droite comme le Front
de gauche qui enregistre 8,63 % des voix
il laisse les électeurs voter en leur
améccience nous on s'est engagé contre
une politique d'économie libérale donc
on va rester sur cette logique là
51,79 % des électeurs du canton ne se
sont pas déplacés ce dimanche un
réservoir d'abstentionniste qui reste à
convaincre avant le 29 mars pour les
deux binôes en
Liss un autre canton détenu jusqu'à
présent par la gauche c'est celui de
saint-cir l'école mais là aussi le duel
avec l'UMP rude les résultats les
réaction c'est avec yolen Torz à présent
détenu par la gauche depuis 1998 le tent
de cincir l'école pourrait peut-être
basculer à droite dimanche prochain le
duo union de la droite Philippe benasaya
et Sonia Bro arrivent en tête du premier
tour avec 39,18 % des voix content de la
mobilisation parce que bien supérieur à
ce qui avait été annoncé et puis content
du résultat je pense que une campagne de
terrain qui a qui a porté ses fruits il
faut continuer à
mobiliser les électeur parce que rien n
jouit mais ce résultat est un bel espoir
il reste une semaine et on va continuer
mobiliser sur la semaine qui va venir
Philippe benasaya réalise le grand
chellem à boisarcy commune dont il est
le maire en remportant tous les bureaux
avec
41,98 % des voix pour autant ils le
savent rien n'est joué face à eux pour
le second tour Fabian gelgomilbau et
Jean-Philippe my conseiller général
sortant socialiste ils ont réuni 24,40 %
des suffrages lors du premier tour pour
nous c'est quand même un motif on va
dire de satisfaction je rappelle
simplement que depuis 3 semaines tous
les Français ont pu voir que tous les
sondages mettaient le Parti socialiste à
très loin derrière en 3e position à 19
20 % donc nous sommes bien bien au-delà
ce canton n'est pas passé à droite il y
a il y aura un deuxième tour et on on va
faire une campagne pour ce deème tour
les trois autres obinô ont été écartés
du second tour en 3e position Julien
grim et perine genunot pour le FN ont
remporté 19,89 % des suffrages des
résultats qu'il qualifie d'encourageant
vient ensuite le binôme front gauche
Europe écologie les vert avec 12,03 % et
enfin debout la France avec 4,50 % des
voix nous prenons je dirais la la
responsabilité
citoyenne nous faisons confiance à nos
électeurs pour prendre la bonne décision
et nous ne donnons pas de de consiges de
vote on est un parti républicain nous
avons des électeurs qui viennent de
droite comme de gauche des électeurs qui
viennent à nous directement et qui ont
des convictions qui ont une réflexion au
premier tour s'ils sont capables de
réfléchir au premier tour je pourquoi on
leur expliquera ce qu'il faut faire au
second debout la France et le
rassemblement Front de Gauche Europe
Écologie Les ver restent toutefois fixé
sur un même objectif continuer leurs
combats respectifs et défendre leur
position au-delà des échéances
électorales 46 % des électeurs se sont
déplacés aux urnes dimanche pour les
deux binôes encore en Liss il reste une
semaine pour mobiliser les
abstentionnistes dernier canton qui nous
intéresse ce soir celui de plaisir même
schéma le canton est à gauche la droite
est là aussi en tête et une bascule et
là aussi possible dimanche prochain
Michel el Mido pour le canton de plaisir
pas de surprise les favoris seront bien
au deuxème tour la liste union de la
droite mené par le duo Joséphine
commansberger Bertrand cocard arriv en
tête avec
36,79 % des voix le Parti socialiste est
second avec 23,53 % des votes le canton
peut donc basculer à droite une première
depuis 2004 je pense qu'avec plus de 16
% d'écart avec le Parti socialiste en
terme de voix oui on ne peut être
qu'optimiste mais au-delà de ça on est
optimiste parce qu'on sait que le projet
que nous avons est un bon projet pour le
canton euh nous avons le soutien des
quatre maires du canton nous faisons
partie à chaquefis des élus de la
majorité nous allons siéger avec la
majorité départementale tout ça fait que
je pense que nous avons les meilleurs
arguments pour représenter au mieux le
canton toujours en course le binôme
socialiste Nicolas Hu Frédéric evrar
espère combler son retard avec les voix
des autre parti de gauche avec une
gauche qui partait un petit peu en ordre
dispersé dans un premier temps sur ce
premier tour euh on pouvait s'attendre à
évidemment ne pas forcément finir devant
madame colmans berger monsieur coca
euh avec l'ensemble des forces de gauche
sur le canton nous avons de très bonnes
chances pour ce second tour que l'on va
entamer de manière dynamique comme on sa
le faire pour pour l'emporter le 29 mars
prochain le Front national réalise lui
une percée sur le canton 3e lors des
dernières élections cantonales de 2011
avec 15,94 % le parti se place une
nouvelle fois sur la dernière marche du
podium le parti totalise cette fois-ci
20,35 % des votes on voit bien que il y
a une adhésion à nos idées et donc on
fera tout on va travailler à nouveau
pour pour se faire connaître encore et
encore et puis de plus en plus
progresser en local parce qu'on se rend
bien compte que le local c'est très très
important pour pour l'avenir à la 4e
place on retrouve les vers avec le duo
Patricia Charton Gérard Levi le réis un
SC de
9,56% nous avons même des taux de 13 % à
Ben par exemple dans le con de de
plaisir ces résultats pour nous c'est
très intéressant puisque nous dépassons
déjà la bague des 5 % et surtout nous
mettons bas les les sondages qui en fait
donn 2
% le binôme du front de gaucheti Mar se
classe 5e avec 5 84 % des voix enfin
debout la France termine dernier de ses
élections cantonales à plaisir avec 3,92
%. déjà on fait le meilleur score que le
Front de Gauche est fait sur le canton
donc forcément on est satisfait pour ce
qui concerne plus particulièrement
plaisir bah on consolide notre position
de force d'opposition donc on est on est
très satisfait donc oui ouis c'est c'est
une belle soirée comp tenu de
l'investissement financier humain qu'on
a mis dedans par rapport aux autres
parties on n'est pas trop mal après
c'est vra que si on compare par rapport
au gros parti on peut croire qu'on a
fait un mauvais score mais quand on
ramène cela l'investissement qu'on a mis
dedans on n pas trop mal et surtout
qu'on a un bon accueil globalement on a
plutôt réussi notre campagne le duel
annoncé donc bien lieu pour ce second
tour l'Union de la Droite représenté par
Joséphine comm Berg Bertrand tentera de
semparer du canton face au duo
socialiste Nicolas et frédrir est-ce que
le secteur basculera à droite réponse
dimanche soir c'est la fin de cette
édition du 78 politique soirée
électorale du second tour dimanche dès
19h45 sur TVfil 78 la campagne va se
poursuivre d'ici là tout au long de la
semaine à travers nos éditions du
journal et puis des débats en direct dès
demain mardi 18h30 la candidate
socialiste Jeanine Marie face au
candidat UMP Jean-Michel Fourgous c'est
pour le canton de trappe très bonne
soirée